all right now Oh Mac romance is back
great okay Malcolm Lance how would you
suggest the u.s. retaliate against
Russian attack we asked you that
question I did since you'll get another
one I see another one here in here for
you don't try not to repeat the
questions already asked to guess since
Trump's performance in Helsinki have any
of your GOP contacts in Congress become
more inclined to believe well let me ask
a different question it's a shitty
question I hear that the Republican
Party is shrinking that but that I hear
this all the time that because Trump's
numbers within the party are so high
it's because the actual number of
Republicans are going down it always
makes me want to ask you how many Steve
Schmidt's are out there how many people
in the Republican Party or who used to
be who are now switching I think it's a
very significant number and I think
you're gonna see college-educated
Republican women in these swing
districts deliver the blue wave for the
Democrats because but the future of the
National Republican Party looks exactly
like the future of the California GOP
which for the first time in history of
the two parties in any state the
Republican Party in this state is now a
third party it's smaller than the
decline of State registrations when you
look at the Aneta that that that
Millennials feel towards the Republican
Party you look at African Americans
brown people you look at just
demographically the country and you
consider that when people imprint on a
political party generationally at 18
years age they remain faithful to that
party really for their lifetimes for
decades and decades and decades so the
Republican Party sometimes a huge huge
huge problem demographically and it's
gonna continue to shrink but as it gets
rancor as is it shrinks it gets smaller
just like the California Republican
Party has it will become crazier but to
the point that I made earlier about the
media stuff this was also not I mean
Trump was an accelerant he has made the
situation worse but weirdly if you look
at data over time of party registration
the decline in Republican registration
in some ways began much
before Trump and it was a lot about
younger voters specifically young women
if you look at what millennial men's
party identification looks like you go
back to the first time Millennials can
vote which think was a 2000 2004 era
millennial men are just as Republican
today as they were then
but for millennial women those numbers
have fallen to where it's a Democrat
plus 50 margin but that streaking party
gets to what you're saying I mean
everything that we see now is about a
shrinking group of Americans trying
their best to enshrine power and
privilege and prestige yes and so they
know that they will there will come a
day when they won't have the numbers to
do it but if they can lock in as much
unchangeable or difficult to change
mechanisms then they will hold on to it
for another chief all that right that
Supreme Court see from brocco bomb right
because you try and something for it
about numbers and if they and if we had
mandatory voting would get close to
winning office if everybody who remains
the rules wherever they get power they
change rule some more and ultimately the
ultimate rules book is the Constitution
and they are taking dead aim at our
Constitution and Brett Kavanaugh is the
coax elected candidate look at how he
came to be through the Federalist
Society long leonard leesia koch was
investing seed money as he yes
federalist society since the 1970s
Cavanaugh is their guy he was selected
by Donald McGann who is a Koch person
who is charm or what Trump's White House
Counsel who did the vetting of these
candidates this is the Koch candidate
for the Supreme Court and that is a
crucial thing that we should be talking
about over the next month okay I was
going to ask about stormy Daniels
it's serious stormy Daniels got arrested
supreme it doesn't you don't find this
alarming that we are now arresting
private citizens yep it's not that it's
stormy but it was a trumped-up charge
set up it was a police setup what do you
think happened what do you think it came
who gave that order or was it order not
needed to be given no order needed to be
given I mean you know it's like the
fight between the brown shirts and the
in the black shirts under Nazi Germany
back that you just hint that you won't
change you win that means rolling up
your political enemies you roll them up
whenever you want to create mayhem it's
like you said you know you have
Nuremberg in the hillbilly Nuremberg and
these people will go out and they will
affect change themselves if that means
walking into a newsroom and killing
everybody in it they'll do it it's
unspoken laws and unspoken orders that
are given out there and as you said
these things are long ballgames they
will change the system to allow these
things to be unpunished
I think it's politically motivated but
it's part and parcel with ice agents for
example in a Concord New Hampshire bus
station walking down the line asking
people for their papers please so that
you're a citizen and so in this country
the only appropriate response when
someone asks you to show your papers and
prove citizenship is to say go [ __ ]
yourself sir right right right
this is the United States of America
we don't have to show papers before we
get on a bus right but but all of this
is is alarming all of it is radical and
we shouldn't be used to it but we got
used to it but the current president
demanding to see the papers of the
previous one it is him signaling and
people saying that is fine with me
and they are kind of falling in line and
doing exactly well this goes way back to
1964 in the Republican Party deciding to
plant his flag in the state everything
else follows that's right it's like in
War of the Worlds the tripods were we're
underground and then they came to the
planet and they came out from
underground we're always under there
look at the first law enforcement
organization that endorsed Trump Border
Patrol and ice they are but you know I
feel sad about this because I love my
law enforcement officers I trained them
in countering terrorism and
counterterrorism intelligence all the
time I engage with them but there is a
block of people right now think that
they are the enforcement arm of the
Trump administration and they are taking
these orders literally like you said New
Hampshire bus station really you think
that there's gonna be illegal immigrants
trying to get on a bus up there they
want to enforce his orders and they're
in the head of ice himself came on
television and said until the orders are
changed that's going to be the orders
locking up kids no problem this is a
malfunction that has to be recalibrated
and when it when we change if we change
this Congress we're gonna have to change
laws to where they're gonna have to obey
the Constitution not got a truck okay
I thought we had those laws but maybe
not all right last question briefly
James asks who in the prospective field
of Democratic candidates do you think
would be most likely to beat Donald
Trump in 2020
what was your ago the essential skill is
going to be somebody who can provoke
Trump have Trump swing at them and then
be smart enough to stand back and not
get into a brawl in the middle of the
Ring but to cut Trump with humor to
laugh at him why is a narcissistic
[Applause]
should be mocked humor is the most
potent the wetware that's why Al Franken
would have been a great great we got rid
of him would you stand up there at
Robert De Niro with all respect he says
[ __ ] you right he's playing Trump's game
is that Godzilla you nuke Godzilla
he just gets stronger right you you try
to out vile Ahnold Trump
yeah and also yeah it's wrong we're
supposed to know the artists and the
poets that's the best we can do [ __ ] you
[Laughter]
name a person well Seth Moulton Tim Ryan
the two young congressman Wow from Ohio
because I think that there's gonna be a
lot of energy for new and you know we
talked about that that loss of affinity
for the Republican Party among women I
mean it looks like the commander's
meeting from The Handmaid's Tale when
these guys I think that whether it's
John Hickenlooper whether it's Eric
Garcetti of this city it's gonna be
someone new cattle Harris out of the out
of the progressive wing but I will add
to that it is very hard to win the
Democratic primary with not be from the
south and you have a name name by from
the south and I think you have to mix
into that group people like mayor
Landrieu of New Orleans and people like
that because the Democratic primary
system swing south so quickly this is
what this how Bernie had a problem he
could have won but he didn't he did not
get into the south quick enough did not
have some message strong enough did not
connect closely enough with those old
the older black women voters and you
have a you know killer Mike's great guy
but
Oh black woman says killer Mike what's a
killer but you know it just does it
right right to you so this idea of like
someone from the Midwest or it could
work but it's hard but there's gonna be
there's gonna be at least two credible
african-american candidates and there
may be three of Governor Patrick runs
all right no they took me seriously when
I we're not doing notes I guess for me I
asked for a briefly a name we got to go
tammy duckworth thank you a name thank
you very much everybody
[Applause]